hello everyone
um I am priyana tarajan the current
director of the Frankie program in
science and the humanities at Yale which
is the flagship interdisciplinary
program
um I'd like to welcome you all to the
final talk in our understanding the
nature of inference series that we've
been hosting at the Frankie program
exploring inferential models reasoning
and experiments across disciplines we've
had a really rich series of talks
exciting talks that have addressed
issues relating to direct causation and
correlation and how multiple modes of
inquiry help us make sense of the world
and make inferences from it
so I invite you all to today's talk with
the Intriguing title inference in a
non-conceptual world by the wonderful
speaker today uh Professor Brian Cadwell
Smith but before I introduce our
distinguished speaker for this evening I
would like to First recognize our
benefactors Mr and Mrs Richard and
Barbara Frankie whose generosity in
funding interdisciplinary activities at
Yale has made all our radical academic
Silo busting activities at the Frankie
program possible I would also like to
thank the John Templeton Foundation for
funding this program of activities
including the colloquium and discussion
series their support has permitted us to
explore in this series a novel format a
colloquium by a distinguished speaker
followed by Deep engagement with an
additional leading thinker after the
colloquium on a separate day in this
case tomorrow afternoon at the same time
this unique format has enabled serious
engagement while giving us some time to
reflect and digest New Concepts that we
learned from the colloquium speaker
while also exposing us to highly
relevant alternate intellectual points
of view from the discussant the
following day
I am also required to kindly remind
those assembled that we are recording
this event and that all participants
videos and microphones will remain muted
if you wish you can submit questions
through the Q a feature
on to today's speaker Professor Brian
Cantwell Smith
Brian Cantwell Smith is the Reed Hoffman
professor of artificial intelligence and
the human as well as being professor of
information philosophy cognitive science
and the history and philosophy of
science and technology and a senior
fellow at Massey college at the
University of Toronto he actually spoke
to us in person about artificial
intelligence the challenges the wins and
the challenges at our program just
before the onset of the pandemic so we
are absolutely delighted to invite him
again he received his degrees all his
degrees in fact from my favorite
undergraduate institution MIT so here I
have to express my loyalty to MIT and
from 81 to 96 he was a principal
scientist at Xerox Park and an adjunct
professor of philosophy at Stanford he
was the founder of the center for the
study of language and information at
Stanford University
um was really ahead of the game in
understanding that information was going
to start playing an incredibly important
role in society culture creation of new
knowledge and really the frontier of
Technology as well he was a founder and
first president of the computer
Professionals for social responsibility
and president for the Society of
philosophy in Psychology and from 1996
to 2001 he was a professor of cognitive
science computer science and philosophy
at Indiana University and from 2001 to
2003 he was the Kimberly Jenkins
University distinguished professor of
philosophy and new technologies and
professor and depart in the Departments
of philosophy and computer science at
Duke University so you get the sense
that Ryan has had his foot in multiple
camps so multiple feet in multiple camps
throughout his academic career so if
there is someone whose intellectual
interests cannot be siled it is him he
is Exemplar of the interdisciplinary
scholarship that we stand for and
Professor Smith moved to the University
of Toronto in 2003 initially to serve as
the dean of the faculty of information
and has stayed there since and our
distinguished conversant tomorrow
afternoon is Professor Joseph Rouse from
Wesleyan University
and his primary research interests are
in the philosophy of science the history
of 20th century philosophy
interdisciplinary science studies and
the social theory of practices I give a
much more detailed introduction to him
before our session tomorrow without
further Ado I am turning the floor over
to Professor Brian Cantwell Smith
welcome Brian it's all yours well thank
you very much Priya and um and thanks to
you and to and to Ty and to guy
um
and um to the um
Frankies and to the Templeton Foundation
and so on and so with all the people
from making this possible and then also
thank you all of those who are attending
um
for a chance to have this conversation
because I really hope it will be a kind
of open-ended conversation but I want to
convince you of if um if I have a chance
is of an orientation but not of an
answer
um to a whole and I think the
orientation opens up all kinds of
questions to which um as far as I know
none of us yet have answers so so that's
what I hope to talk about
um there are four parts to this are
actually five in a way I'm going to talk
about conceptual representation first
and then the conceptual world
second and then non-conceptual
representation third and the
non-conceptual world fourth and then on
epilogue on explainability
um I want to make one remark before we
start um about Ai and contemporary AI
um I won't be talking all that much
about AI but some towards the end but
one thing that's true is I've been in
and around AI for a long time uh in fact
I'm pretty ancient
um I wrote my first uh big AI program in
1968. um and there have been a lot of
changes since then needless to say there
was the first wave enthusiasm and then
long periods of AI winter and a lot of
different weather in there and a
Resurgence of second wave Ai and stuff
what's interesting to me and sobering is
that today so for example when I teach
classes I'm just finishing one up this
fall
the word AI
the moniker AI but also the word
artificial intelligence means
statistical generalizations over massive
amounts of data that's what the students
just think this is
um a particular kind of data too
corpuscular non-narrative data the sort
of data that can go into databases or
else decontextualized text strings
and as I've argued in a recent book
um there's no real serious attempt to
get these systems to understand what
they're talking about and I think
um they're sort of pure there's a
wonderful phrase of
of
uh Timber and others um called
statistical
um parents that's how they characterize
these systems as statistical parents and
I think there's a lot of Truth to that
um I don't think there's any real
semantics to these today's systems and
some people think that with enough
syntax you get semantics which I think
is
about as wrong as thinking that if you
travel fast enough in strange loops on
two Dimensions you're going to end up in
a third dimension
um so I think AI at the moment is in a
very particular and rather narrow
conception that's not how it started
um when I was in MIT in the 70s
um
you know a lot of people were inspired
by the Golem the the the the myth from
from
uh uh from from Jewish mystical history
in a way that the idea was that man was
created in God's image was a recursive
claim because if man was in creating
God's image then that meant man could
create in God's image as well and stuff
a lot of the early um
pioneers of AI at MIT like um Marvin
Minsky one of the founders of the field
Gerald Sussman um Joel Moses who went on
to be president of the University
admitted not necessarily publicly that
they'd been inspired by the Golem myth
as as as children and the idea was that
we would understand understanding we
would understand The Human Condition we
would understand our place in the
universe and how
where we came from and so on and so
forth Barbara Minsky proposed we buy a
church and put a computer on the altar
um
now that was a little
imperialist but there was I think a a
Grandeur to that original division which
I think has been lost
and I think
um I think the aim of this talk is not
to indict current models of AI but when
I talk about it I I I you should know
that I come from that tradition and I'm
not referring to the current narrow view
I'm actually referring to
things that might allow us to move from
the current narrow View to a much bigger
broader maybe we're inspiring vision
okay anyway part one conceptual
representation um
so when philosophers particularly talk
about the content of a representations
they refer to
something like what it means or how it
presents the world as being
so the content might be that
thanks for driving up in front of the
Supreme Court or God knows what it is
um
we could spend a a semester on the
relationship between
um what something means and how it
presents the world as being
um but I don't need to um I don't need
to do it to that I just think for the
moment a sort of informal notion of
meaning
um will do in 1982 Gareth Evans a
philosopher at Oxford introduced the
notion of non-conceptual content
now non-conceptual content if anything
is obvious it's defined in opposition to
the National conceptual content and so
the question was what intent conceptual
content was and that kind of triggered a
a whole debate
basically I'm going to talk about it
more but conceptual content was
the kind of content that everybody
assumed up until then um and underlies
every form of logic that you have ever
imagined um um including fuzzy logic I
mean it's just the sort of model
um
a model in which all these formal
systems are based
okay what what is it in particular
conceptual content
very roughly a conceptual representation
is a representation that represents the
world in terms of objects properties
relations sets attributes and so on and
so forth
um as in logic as in model Theory as in
classical AI gophi as John Hogan called
it
um as in XML and so on and so with it's
just an extraordinarily widespread view
about how the world is and how what it
is to represent it um
what else in fact could it be
um
so we'll get to that in a minute
but I want to say something about how
conceptual content is being theorized
two philosophers in particular
um have written in deep ways about the
notion of conceptual content
um
people of enormous intelligence um
Gareth Evans who I mentioned who
introduced the notion of non-consentful
content he was an awful on terrible at
Oxford um he died
30
34 I think having done a huge amount of
work um
here's an idea of conceptual content was
a representation that's algebraically
structured so I'm just going to share
the screen here for a second
um
he he articulated what he called the
generality condition
basically
a representation is conceptual if it
says a is f you know that's somebody is
tall or
you know
the storm is going to be intense or
something like that
if and only if the system that's
representing that is capable of
entertaining the thought or representing
or whatever not only that ASF but also
that b is f and c is f and so on and so
forth for any other B and C of which it
has a conception and also that a is G
and a is H and so on for any a g and H
are pointed as conception modulo various
condition appropriation conditions so
you know beans or green might be okay
dreams are green famous sentence of
chomskies doesn't quite fit because
dreams don't have a color so that's an
appropriate condition but the logical
structure takes that form
um
note that this generality condition is
not framed in terms of syntax but it
lends itself to being read syntactically
which is to say if a representation has
the form of a is f or F of a
um syntactically then that system is
capable of writing down G of a or
h of a or H or B or whatever
since contemporary I I reads everything
syntactically in fact it's defined all
kinds of words including semantics to be
words of syntax that's a discussion
point
um
this conception of conceptuality is very
fits swimmingly with current conceptions
of AI and so on and so forth so a lot of
people may I just think that this um
that Evan's generality condition applies
to their structures directly
John McDowell perhaps one of the most
important philosophers in the last 50
years
um
um has a different edition of
being conceptual he says that a
representation is essential if it
transparency represents the world as it
is
I.E it fits into a judgment about
the world not a complete judgment about
the world because there's no such
judgment that would be too big but a
judgment about a complete world in the
sense the world is at whole
um on the face of it McDowell's
characterization is much less syntactic
it doesn't have to do with the structure
of the representation itself
and also to be honest I don't think
McDowell's characterization is anything
that anyone in AI or any system and AI
is capable of meeting because it has to
be about the world
but they're not exactly the same
so let's turn to Part B sorry part two
about the conceptual World why are these
two characterizations of conceptual
thought to be sort of the same or at
least comparable at least compatible
the reason they're viewed is the same I
think by most people and in fact a lot
of people don't distinguish between
these two characterizations I think the
reason they're thought to be compatible
is because of an ontological assumption
that underlies people's understandings
of them
um and I'm not a logical assumption
being an assumption about the structure
of the world not a structure of
representation or thought but the
structure of the world itself
and uh
that basically
representations that are structured
according to this generality condition
of Evans represent the world as it
really is
so I'm going to extend ordinary usage
and use the word conceptual not just for
representations but for the world
thereby represented
and I will say that a conceptual world
is a familiar World in a way to our
imaginations of objects properties
relations sets and stuff that the world
itself consists of objects exemplifying
properties standing in relations grouped
together in sets exemplifying properties
with attributes and so on and so forth
um
so
so sending Evans and McDowell's
definitions aside I'm going to actually
take conceptual in my usage as any
content that has this ontological
character and the content that
represents the world in terms of object
properties relations and so on and so
forth
um now
this assumption that that's what the
world likes that's what the world is
like is extraordinarily widespread
um and it's um
so widespread that in fact it's
difficult with students to actually
motivate them or enable them or
something lead them to believe that
anything else might even be possible
um I want to point to a wonderful paper
of Jeffrey nunberg who in fact passed
away just recently
on the rise of information Jeffrey's an
extremely smart guy he's such a smart
guy that it's actually sometimes
difficult to figure out that his papers
are as profound as they are
um but he wrote a paper called farewell
to the information age which
but if we don't get to the far well
first of all he starts about actually
when did the information arise he's
tracing the notion of information
when did it actually enter
our conceptions
uh Priya pointed out that information is
a hugely important notion now underlies
all kinds of technical projects
scientific projects
um but he wants to know sort of when was
it invented as it were
um
and he goes back to the to through
history to the rise of print basically
when print became in fact a common form
of public discourse
and
his his
sense is that print led to the idea of
Snippets of text being extractable and
recombinable in ways that actually could
then convey content about the world like
the temperature is 96 degrees or
um you know pine trees are green or
whatever it might be
um
and his characterization of information
is that it was the idea that the nature
of the world is such that it can be
reduced to these corpuscular compact
little bits of quote unquote information
right in fact Jeff's uh Jeff's such a
colorful guy he um
I once asked him I don't know if this is
in print or not but it's What What In
fact information was and he said oh
information that's what happens when you
take a book and you shake it by the
spine so hard that all the words fall
out
and I think that's a good way to
remember
is his sense that it's it's the sort of
erosion of any sense that narrative is
the locus of our our understanding and
instead that our claims about the world
are in fact come in these little bits
there are other assumptions underlying
this notion of information too that the
properties or concepts and stuff that
these bits of the world exemplify are
uniform across all instances so all pine
trees not that are all the same but in
being a pine tree they're Pine treeness
is uniform across all pine trees
um and and and and so on and so forth um
so that you could in fact have pine tree
as the type of a plant in
a database or something like that
um
Brian I have a great question yes
this kind of getting to the essence of
the pine tree nest right sort of the
essential does it always imply a
reduction reductionism
well if
boy I wish I had a
bottle of whiskey and I could pour
virtual bottles glasses of whiskey
around um it doesn't imply reductionism
I mean first of all reductionism is not
itself technically particularly well
defined one version of reductionism is
that there's a basic foundational set of
fundamental Primitives like
physical Primitives or something like
that and that
um you can build
everything up out of them
this assumption which I'm going to
necessarily have a good name for but
it's not that it you might have
you know Midwife in a database or
you know um
um user friendly as a characterization
of a system
um and you'd still think that user
friendly is a is a sort of formal
Concept in the sense that it can be
applied to something without actually
thinking you can reduce any of the
concepts to any others so you could have
gazillion you could have every word in
the dictionary in there
um so it's not actually reductionist in
the classic sense it does have a bit of
character of reduction of everything to
these corpuscular bits
but not
to an underlying level out of which
they're assembled so that's just an
important distinction um thank you yeah
for that clarification
okay so so so let's turn to
non-conception conceptual representation
um
as I say it was introduced by uh Gareth
Evans in 1982 he's an awful on terrible
of
Oxford I actually knew him and uh
at MIT is a graduate student by
coincidence and by my luck um and he
Strode I would meet him at two in the
morning I mean not by plan I would just
run into him at two in the morning in
Cambridge and he would be striding
around and he thought Cambridge Mass was
not a big enough place to do philosophy
because there was not a place for long
walks in the middle of night um but
anyway he introduced the notion of
non-conceptual representation
now
because it was Evans when he said
non-conceptual representation he was
obviously characterizing it as
non-conceptual with respect to his own
definition of conceptuality so it was
the algebraic you know kind of algebraic
combination of Parts asfb is H and so on
and so worth not to McDonald's
his introduction of the notion of
non-conceptional content led to quite a
debate about
what non-conceptual is non-conceptual
content is the fact that it's negatively
defined doesn't help there's a question
of whether you could have non-conceptual
judgments in thought or only in
perception you could have a question of
whether they just occurred in action
there was a question of whether
creatures that don't have conceptual
powers like simple animals and stuff can
actually exhibit can actually have a
non-consensual judgment and so on this
horrible
what are some examples so to give you a
feel Heaven's had this example of being
in this study late at night
and there being a thinking he's
completely alone and there's a step on
the floor
um unmistakable step on the floor right
behind him and he freezes in Terror
now he knows exactly where that footstep
happened right it's just his his
imagination is riveted
but he doesn't have conceptual Resources
with which to describe that space it's
not like
137.6 degrees to my right end
2.1 meters behind me or something like
that it just wasn't he wasn't given to
him in conceptual form and yet it
um
and yet it was it had content and it was
very precise
um similarly if I'm teaching tennis
which God knows you don't want to have
happen but anyway suppose I tell someone
to hit their
second serve suppose their second
service going out and I say look you're
hitting it too hard just hit it at the
speed at which paper is ejected from the
big copier in the office of in your
department or something
it's not clear I mean that's a speed and
you know that the paper is coming out of
the copy at a certain speed but
you don't know what speed that is in any
way that
you know like miles an hour and even if
it did it's not fair you would be able
to hit a serve at that many miles an
hour it's that form of understanding of
speed that you have both for papers
ejected from copiers and for for tennis
service they're not
they're not conceptually formulated
um Adrian cousins a a philosopher who
was a postdoc of mine
way back when
um in the 80s I guess he got a PhD in
Oxford and he was stopped he wrote a
motorcycle
um late at night so maybe this late at
night is a theme of this talk
he stopped by the police
um and uh they all hauled him up and
said look do you know how fast you were
going
and Adrian said well in one way I know
and in one way I don't know
which I don't think was a good thing to
say to police but what he meant was he
knew how fast he was going around the
corner it was wet and it was Sandy and
he knew that he could go only that fast
before skidding out he could probably do
it again and without a very small margin
of error repeat the same velocity but it
was not given to him conceptually he
didn't know how many kilometers per hour
he was going and whether he was over the
speed limit I probably knew he was over
his name but but the point is his sense
of that speed was not conceptually
um
articulated and so on and so forth Evans
argued
that a great deal of our
knowledge especially perceptual
knowledge is in this
non-conceptual form
now that notion of non-conceptual
content of Evans did drive a bit of a
wedge through Evans and McDowell
um a way it's not well understood um
for example some of you go to a
furniture store and you are with your
partner and uh
and you say to them look hey should we
buy those curtains and your partner says
no look that red won't go with our sofa
now what does that red refer to it
refers to a shade of red
um
there are different shades of red
you know some might be might kind of
blood and occult ceremonies and Burgundy
wine another might come out lipstick and
Orlon sweaters and Muffy at a prep
school dance
for Evans those are different judgments
um and the differences matter as regard
conceptuality because they differ
but those differences matter with
respect to conceptuality because how it
is that those different
differences manifest in your mind is not
conceptually explicable to you
so that judgment that red is whatever
not the right one is not a conceptual
judgment on Evans part
for McDowell it's a different judgment
too but with respect to defense of
conceptuality he doesn't care because
that's a judgment about the nature of
the world which is given to you in your
understanding of the world so he thinks
that's a fine conceptual judgment
so cracks started to appear in this
whole debate
um
which I'm not going to go into
I want to push though on the notion of
non-conceptual content because if we go
deeper I think we start to open stuff up
in ways that touch contemporary Ai and
possibilities for inference and stuff
okay so part four the non-conceptual
world
I myself have never believed that the
world oath was conceptual
it may have stemmed from my Misfit youth
um
being um
um taking place in the Canadian north um
so
so I used to go paddling around in
Whitewater Rivers um
and I just don't think there are objects
out there I mean of course there's some
objects there's rocks but but if we're
talking about re-identifiable
particulars under a category you know
what category Rock exactly is this and
how many rocks are there there the thing
underneath the water on the right is
that one or is it 17 or is that Bedrock
um if you're going to characterize rocks
there's no sort of natural boundary
between the rocks and Pebbles and sand
and God knows what all
um one of the things that you have to do
in paddling white water is you've got to
go into the into the arrow of a v of
Dark Water pointing away from you
um and your life is often at stake if
you do this wrong
um but how many V's are there in this
picture
um I don't know
um
um
if you're paddling through this
Maelstrom of spray
and waves and rocks and clouds and all
this kind of stuff
there's no way to individuate I mean you
may have enormous skill but there's no
way to individuate what's going on in
ways that conceptual representations
require
um
I think the way conceptual
representations work is different from
how they are
classically conceived and Priya this
actually gets a little bit at your idea
about whether this whole view of
conceptual representation is
is reductive
um my sense is that conceptual content
informs a form of abstraction over a
fundamentally profuse richness in the
underlying world that is essentially a
conceptual achievement
to box and and and
struck categories and so on and so forth
in order to bring things out there under
a regimen of intelligibility
um
and
um that that's sort of the the the the
norm on conceptual representation is to
render the world intelligible by
abstraction
um now how does this work um if you'll
forgive me I'm going to actually put up
a
another slide don't you forget this is a
waterfall plot for people who know about
such things it doesn't matter suppose
this um
suppose This was
um a sort of topographic set of vertical
slices through a landscape at the edge
of a lake or something like this
um
and I suppose somebody says look
um
we should go up one of the two ridges
towards the left end of this picture
what are they referring to by the two
ridges you know one possibility is that
those are the two ridges they're
referring to another possibility is that
they're the left two are the ones that
they're referring to and I think the one
on the right is is different from what
it was that the person on the right
um thought and so on and so forth
um
so in other words the the category Ridge
the property of being a ridge here is
being imposed by an epistemic mind on an
underlying World which is in fact much
richer that in fact those categories can
in fact do justice too
um another example
there's an artist by the name of Adam
Lowe a a good friend of mine who and
we've talked about what the world's like
and and uh
and he painted this picture
this is meant to be a realistic picture
but in the following sense that if
our perception renders the world's
richness intelligible by our packaging
it up and labeling it and categorizing
it and smoothing the boundaries and so
on and so forth
he couldn't paint a picture of what the
world was like and to make any point
because our perceptual apparatus would
be looking at the picture and it would
just
constructs a picture in categories and
smooth out the boundaries and so on and
so over there we just look like a
picture so he's not an algebraist but to
put this in algebraic terms if you
assume that perception computes F of a
scene what he's painted here is a
conception his conception of f to the
minus one of that scene in other words
this differs from reality
by the amount by which we in fact smooth
out reality in order to fit it into our
conceptual scheme so that when our
perception sees this it's actually given
to us in our judgment as something like
the raw material with respect to which
we see the world in general
and um
what's interesting about this is I can
completely read this picture I don't
know if you can and I apologize it's
probably not the best on this um on Zoom
but I'll just point out some things
there's a door over here
with some Lumber inside and a and a
step letter meaning over and stuff you
can sort of tell that down here there's
a pail that's not too hard to see
on the right hand
um um
what's it called anyway the right hand
side of the doorway there's a mobile
phone in a 1980s kind of mobile phone
um
anchored to the right hand post there
excuse me
um there's a box yeah in there inside
the room with lots of sticks of kindling
sized wood and so on and so forth and
over here is a person crossing over to
to
um
and actually to pick up the phone it
turns out from other aspects of this
picture and so on and so forth
um
you don't necessarily read these things
as door and pale and box and person and
so on and so over then telephone
immediately but what he's sort of
claiming this picture is
we actually do do that kind of
classification categorization on inputs
and one of the things that's sobering
about AI is when AI first put television
cameras on systems back you know 150
years ago when I was young people were
astounded by the messiness of the world
that the cameras
that were the camera outputs because
they thought that in fact the camera was
looking at like nice scenes of
you know nice
scenes of vases of flowers on tables or
something like this um still life
and it was a mess it was a mess and
people were astounded that oh my God we
we deal with this mess
um so
so the point is this this orientation
says that look
the fact that in what philosophy
actually calls our natural attitude the
fact that we take the world to be
conceptual to be consisting of objects
and properties and categories and stuff
um
that's not how it actually is in and of
itself it's a human achievement the fact
that it looks like it is that way and in
fact a lot of philosophy has been
distracted into thinking that it just is
that way Aboriginal
is because that in fact has been
processed by the very cognition we're
trying to understand
so okay so suppose I tell this to
students and they say well what else
could it be
now it's hard to answer that in language
especially in intellectual contexts like
iei courses and philosophy courses and
so on and so forth
in intellectual context such as science
philosophy and so on and so forth in
which people assume that language is
conceptual in the sense that we talked
about before
it would not be as hard to convey in a
sense in a in a classroom or a community
or something of people who are not
themselves
scientists or philosophers or AI people
and stuff it was a
you know a class of poets or something
like that it would be easier I think to
get them to realize that in fact the
world doesn't come chopped up in this
corpuscular way that nunberg um talked
about
it
so how can I convey to you what the
world might be like
well I want to make one suggestion I'm
going to make other suggestions before
the end of this talk and this first
suggestion is just by way of oh prying
openness
this this possibility I'm not trying to
put too much weight on it
in a 1964 book called individuals uh
Peter strassen introduced the notion of
a feature I mean not exactly introduced
but I mean developed under another
feature as something more basic and less
committing less ontologically committing
than a property
as something that could be exemplified
in space and time
um manifested in space and time without
actually needing an object for its
exemplification
excuse me
so suppose I say it's raining or we say
it's foggy
everybody knows that there's no it that
is foggy or no it that's raining
it's a kind of linguistic it's actually
called the weather it's in linguistics
it's an it that doesn't refer
but
but the idea of features is that look
the features are just manifested in
absolutely rich ways
throughout the world
um cross-cutting and in vortices and so
on and so forth without actually
requiring object identities underneath
them
one way to imagine this is to imagine
falling overboard in a storm at sea
surrounded by nothing but crashing waves
and stinging spray and undulating
currents and so on and so forth as far
as the eye can see and then subtract U
so there are no objects there at all
I think that in fact the world of
physics now feels a physicist so um so I
look forward to her
coming in this I I actually think that's
kind of what the world is like according
to physics
um
you might not think that it's that way
because
physics in fact often talks in terms of
objects
you know there's a mass of three
kilograms traveling at this four meters
per second off slides of a tail a meter
high where does it land
um the various objects in this situation
a mass of three kilograms a table and so
on
um
but those objects are not ontological
commitments of physics those objects are
epistemic practices of doing physics
theoretical Enterprise so that we can in
fact work out our equations but the
equations don't quantify over the
objects they quantify
over the measures of the properties or
features that in fact are exemplified
um
and even if you think about the
gravitational law um T times M1 times M2
divided by r squared I think if I recall
correctly
um
one of the things you do in your first
year physics class at least I did
um 150 years ago was you prove that in
fact you can treat masses as Point
masses at the location of the center of
gravity four purposes of calculating
gravitational attraction but that's not
the ontological commitment of the
physics underlying it the analogical
commitments of physics underlying it is
that in fact mass is the you know it's a
density field spread out over a region
and if you really wanted to express the
law of gravity in a way that actually
didn't make this epistemic assumption
for the physicists you would have to
express the law of gravity as a double
triple integral and so on and so forth
because there aren't objects in physics
I think that's right and I actually
don't think there are many objects in
science either
um so um so that will generate a lot of
cortisol I suspect in many uh audience
members
but I think that idea I mean it goes
with field theoretic interpretations and
physics more too that idea that maybe
you could make sense of physics as a
kind of characterization of features
placed continuously in the world the
fact that that might be intelligible
suggests that features might be an
intelligible way of taking the world to
be which means that in fact conceptual
ontology isn't necessarily the only way
to take the analogical structure of the
world and that's really why I want them
here
however features are problematic too um
because in fact the whole Assumption of
features like in
real heretic interpretations is that the
feature is the same feature that's
exemplified in lots of different places
and so on and so forth
so it's just a step towards
relinquishing the
the grip of the conceptual ontology as a
presupposition for how the world is
structured
their way that we can go or a way that
we can go deeper a little bit is to see
how conceptual and non-conceptual
representation okay the two epistemic
practices we talked about
might fit into an amount of physical or
ontological picture of this sort of a
world of surpassing stupefying
um richness and operate as kinds of
abstraction over it um
so four points
first point is that this is not and this
is another form of reductionism that
this is not to go to priya's great
question
it is not a view that the world is built
up from atoms or Elementary pieces or
ultimate constituents of our ontological
life and that in fact complex or high
level or something objects are in fact
assemblages of lower levels
it's more like a jamesian blooming
buzzing confusion conception of the
world but not in the sense into which
James is often understood that the
blooming doesn't conversion is under
undifferentiated K-pop
rather what I'm trying to get at is an
idea that the world is sort of
infinitely heterogeneous stupefyingly
complex and that we navigate and wrestle
it into comprehensible form in order to
make our way in our
you know in our paltry resource limited
lives um
so I another point
one Merit of this view that conceptual
ontology is an epistemic achievement on
top of a world of surpassing richness is
that it provides a way to account for
the most important Insight I think and
commitment underlying science studies
underlying feminist epistemology and so
on and so forth the concepts are
normative and not just Concepts but
objects they are the locus of value they
are culturally relative all these kinds
of stuff
how does it make room for that because
in fact what it suggests is that a
conceptual abstraction of the world
so a conceptual judgment is true when
the thereby abstracted situation what
you take the ridge to be and so on and
so forth satisfies the Norms the dynamic
Norms governing the lives of the
creatures who perform it
so if um
Priya is a geologist and I'm a mountain
climber and I climb a peak in the
Kalani Wilderness in Yukon where there's
a mount Robinson I think is 19 000 feet
and I say oh look I've climbed the
highest peak in
you know or whatever this is the last
Peak over eight thousand meters or
something it probably isn't seven
thousand meters or something like that
doesn't matter I'm a philosopher so I
don't need to deal with pesky facts
um
if I say I climbed all of the seven
thousand meter Peaks
and Priya says no look you haven't
because you're on this peak but over
there about
seven meters to the right it dips a
little bit and then there's another
little rise and so that technically is a
peak and you haven't been there
now I could say look that's not what I
mean by Peak that's not the
category Peak that I'm using for my
climbing
and it might be a category Peak that
she's using for her Geological Survey or
something like this but the point is
that how to understand my category of
peak is with respect to mountain
climbing and the Norms of government
mountain climbing and so on and so forth
this is what the feminine systemologists
I think are are on about incorrectly so
Ryan quick question
there needs to be a consensus right on
the definition of peak even amongst just
the mountain climbers
a definition of a peak to be some part
of objective reality that cannot be
contested by anyone
well I I am
Lo there be lawyers um
I actually don't think that there are
I mean they're
the structure of agreement and
consensuality and communion and so on
and so forth that's a huge Topic in
science studies as to how that stuff
gets worked out there was a famous case
of a racehorse which crossed
and so which of course run the won the
race and there was one horse and its
nose looked like it was further ahead
than the one behind but the one behind
was like an inch behind or something the
writer argued that it had won the race
because in fact there was spittle coming
out of the nostril of the horse that was
behind and the spittle was continuous
with respect to the
that horse and that the spittle crossed
the Finish Line before
the nose of the other one did and so
that constituted that horse winning and
it went to court how many went to court
as you could imagine such things I think
the second verse one actually but it
doesn't matter who won it's that
there has to be good enough agreement
for practices to work
and I think it's it's it's it's it's
just not true that
um categories in general get resolved
absolutely
there are there's politics there's
politics and uh
um and you know sometimes there's been
really permission pernicious politics
behind these judgments you know who's a
person and stuff who gets to vote you
know right now with respect to whether
in fact it's illegal to put a pregnant
woman in prison because you're putting
two people in prison you know that's
that category is absolutely not well
underneath so there be politics I think
oh okay but but but the point is this is
this is a huge
this is a huge issue in I mean it's
something we could talk to Joe Russ
about tomorrow
the sort of politics of the net of the
negotiation of conceptual agreement and
so on and so within different fields a
big topic I think um
um
thank you here really is just that the
the metaphysical picture here that in
fact the concepts and categories and
stuff are abstractions in terms of which
we try to fit reality
is that
um
okay
are they out there in the objective
world
well
here's the thing
it's generally accepted in philosophy
that semantics needs naturalizing we
need an account of semantics of how
reference works and how thought works
and so on and so forth
what I'm saying here is that ontology in
the sense of conceptual ontology what an
object is that needs naturalizing too
because the process of abstraction that
underwrite the grouping and
individuation into individuals and so on
and so forth which is essential to our
understanding of cognition our no less
mysterious and no more secured by a
mechanistic or causal scientific
worldview no more autonomously
integrable with results in contemporary
science than any other of the challenges
and features of intentionality so for
example if an amoeba split is that two
new amoeba or is one of the same one or
is it one that is duly instantiated in
the world if you have a redwood tree and
there's all kinds of fronds is like what
they're called growing up out of the
roots and some of these things are can
be 30 feet tall and so on and so forth
are those lots of different redwood
trees or the same redwood tree you know
science remarkably doesn't care about
such things I think because I don't
think as I said before I don't think
science is actually committed to
conceptual ontology
um
and I think to assume as so much of
philosophy and logic and XML and so on
and so forth assume that the world of
objects properties and Zone exists
independently of us and objectively and
so on and so forth is essentially to
suggest that the world is autonomously
conceptual
and that's an especially pernicious way
of accommodate What's called the myth of
the given in philosophy um
but
but and and this is an important but and
it's really really tough to convey um
on this picture conceptual content okay
the epistemic nature of conceptuality so
the nature that I talked about in the
conceptual representation part of the
talk not the conceptual World part of
the talk and it's acceptable
representation part that's relevant to
logic involves loss that's what
abstraction means throw away
it you throw away vast amounts of detail
why in order to support generalization
and long distance inference so for
example um one thing I learned when I
moved to California is in New England if
you wander around the countryside and
you get lost
if you want to find a road you go down
to the bottom of the valleys because
that's where the roads are
in California when you're wandering
around outside San Francisco in the
Santa Cruz mountains and you want to
find a road you go to the top of the
ridge they're not at the bottom of the
ridge
now that's a generalization and that
generalizes over all of the differences
between these ridges and so on and so
forth
generalizations of the sort that fit
into logical inference require letting
go of massive amounts of detail
but
what about the ridge that in fact we
identified in that picture or the ridge
that I climb up in order to find a road
or something like that
experience
think of the ridge is in those waterfall
plots
even if I register it as a as an object
by abstracting away from the details the
ridge itself is not thereby abstracted
and the reference of the phrase that
Ridge is not necessarily abstracted
either
so if I say look I'm going to climb that
Ridge and you say look you're never
going to make it you may be referring to
the richness of the ridge itself not to
the richness of it registered as a
bridge
um
go back to that picture of Whitewater
ahead at the beginning um if you argue
that I mean another part of philosophy
is it talks about issues of vagueness
that words like Rapid or Eddie or
something are vague because maybe
there's no facts no absolute effects in
the matter as to how many Rapids or
Eddies or something there are in that
picture
but again the vagueness if it's I think
it's mistakes they call it vagueness but
even if it were okay to call it Vegas
um there's nothing vague about the river
if you're paddling down that River and
your life's at stake there's nothing you
don't run into anything vague you run
into extremely concrete
detail
what's vague if anything is
is our epistemic description of it as a
Eddie or a rapid or something like this
and more more more more importantly
it's interesting that if you want to
actually act if you want to put your
finger just there where the wind is
strongest or track the pattern of animal
motion against the background of grasses
or flip through a crack in a wall or
something
then the rich detail is necessary for
fine-grained action
in other words the superfluity of detail
because it's so detailed is not good for
long distance reasoning and planning or
inference but it's absolutely necessary
for Action so suppose I want to reach
for a cup here of coffee which I don't
have but unfortunately
and I say okay I'm going to pick up this
cup and I reach out
now if you look at slow motion videos of
this kind of stuff it's kind of
remarkable I may think that I'm going to
pick up the cup that that's a conceptual
thought and it may be that the
conceptual thought leads my hand in that
direction but as I get close to it there
are some conceptual representations that
kind of take over and adjust my fingers
and my hand and Orient my hand and so on
and so forth
through non-conceptual representation so
as to be prepared to more exactly know
how they should pick the cup up so that
I don't dump it
and the same thing for serving tennis or
meaning and the quarter on a motorcycle
or something
so to try to wrap up here a little bit
representing or otherwise dealing with
the local ever so rich feature array or
or even more stupefying detail in the
world is good for controlling action and
good for responding to fine detail but
it's bad for long distance inference and
generality
this leads to a picture of what I call
metaphysical monism but ontological
pluralism
because what happens is we people maybe
other creatures too
live in a continuous creative tension
between the incredible richness of the
world
and the long distance utility of
language abstraction and inference on
the other
when we engage with the world we want to
do the operative abstraction we want to
kind of reconcile or concretize our
ideas with respect to reality to let
more of the world's ineffable details
fill our representations in order to be
appropriately responsive in action
um to the world's fine Grace
fine-grained detail but when we want to
travel long distances by which I mean
maybe conceptual long distances we want
to figure out where in fact we're going
to put in Mine in Northern Canada we can
go into where the neutrino flux will be
the highest when the Sunspot arrives or
whatever
in order then we have to in fact
um to do science we have to let go of a
lot of detail and employ Sparrow more
efficient methods purposely designed for
inferential travel
and if we're clever and we're damn
clever I think there's nothing more
important about AI than it teaches you
humility
we must in fact do both
basically living in this middle realm
between engaging with the detail letting
go of the detail allowing different
forms of representation conceptual or
not and so on and so forth to to allow
us both to think and to act
and
yeah I sometimes think of
objects properties and relations in
other words the conceptual material of
ontology the material of conceptual
intelligence I think of the object
properties in relations the things we
started with as the long distance trucks
and Interstate Highway systems of
intentional normative life
undeniably essential to overall
integration of life's practices
crucial given finite resources for us to
integrate to vast open-ended terrain of
experience into a single cohesive
objective world
but the cost of packaging them up for
portability and long distance travel
is that it insulates them from the
extraordinary fine-grade richness of the
particular indigenous life the ineffable
richness of the very lives they sustain
and what's Magic about us is that we
live this dance between them among them
so as to both live and be able to think
okay so that's that's the end of part
four and uh if I have two more minutes
um I'm just gonna say this epilogue um
which I think is kind of interesting
this thing about a contemporary AI
systems right they end up doing
inference which is not obviously
conceptual and you know you end up with
vectors you know ten thousand
dimensional vectors or something with
real numbers and so on and other words
and it just you have this incredible
richness
there's a huge amount of pressure to
make explicable right to explain these
things which basically means look render
these judgments into conceptual form
and I think part of the picture I'm
arguing is look that's you've got to be
careful about that
I know Priya when I see her and I think
if I ran into her in the streets of
Miami where I didn't expect her
um I would say oh my God you're in Miami
what brings you here
and then if somebody comes up behind me
and says how do you know that's free I
am in a bloody clue
because my recognition of Priya as Priya
is in fact not conceptually available to
me it's probably not actually in
conceptual form at all because I
probably don't have Concepts that are
actually adequate to the detail that I
use to in fact recognize this particular
person
so how do we explain
well I've got one more slide
here's a very short sentence just 23
words it's the first sentence of uh
Henry James portrait of a lady which for
some reason I remembered all my life
under certain circumstances there are
few hours in life more agreeable than
the hour dedicated to the ceremony known
as afternoon tea
now think about afternoon tea about that
concept if you like it
what I think is interesting is
you know our current models of logic
would take afternoon tea is referring to
the concept of afternoon tea which is a
concept of exemplified by all
forms of afternoon tea
but that's not a god-given Insight that
that's necessarily afternoon tea means
or refers to
and you can think of James as actually
very clever and you know Steinbeck's
another author is amazing at this just
with a few words can actually
lead a concept to in fact have a
specificity that absolutely transcends
our ability to get at it with a single
word
and from AI point of view you can see
how this might work if you if you get
all of the other variables arranged in
such a way that they can
sort of focus in on what it is that this
concept is getting at in this particular
circumstance that you're in fact
abstracting in certain sorts of ways
I actually think it might be a
inspiration as to how to explain things
so if you said to some medical system
um look what do you think we should do
why are you prescribing this drug
anxiety drug or something and imagine
the system saying well look it's as if
this guy was told that they were about
to experience a huge shock as if waiting
for a diagnosis after surgery but they
actually have only the vagus premonition
of what it's going to be about
or she's going to be in a she's in a
state reminiscent of the one that her
sister experienced after sailing
single-handedly across the Roaring 40s
on our solo trip to Antarctica's one
go back to what nunberg said about how
the chopping up of narrative into
corpuscular bits at the beginning of the
age of information gave us this notion
of corpuscular recombinable recombinable
um
corpuscular data
but somehow we're trying to mine it for
the richness of the world
that might be wrong it might be that we
need to realize that novels and poetry
and
letters and then a narrative
is actually a locus of the understanding
that fine-tunes things in such a way
that you can get a better sense of the
richness of the world that these things
are about
and what would be the consequence of
actually taking that on board as an
epistemic ontological assumption for the
future of AI
um
I don't know
but
I appreciate your attention
thanks very much
thank you so much Brian for this
absolutely wonderful talk
um addressing so many important deep
issues in what constitutes conceptual
understanding and therefore informs
inferences there from
um that was a real right that's right
can I interrupt all right
Brian knows that I'm not easily shut up
um
our current models of inference Arkansas
and I think that the Intriguing
possibility is that the second wave AI
although we don't understand how is
showing this inference may actually not
need to be conceptual and we may not
know how to explain it
but it may show us that inference can in
fact occupy other places in this realm
so I just think I mean I don't think you
probably disagree with that I just think
it's interesting right so uh no I know
with you that I have to be extra careful
with the language right so you always
catch me on everything so I want to um
why don't I start off with uh one sort
of question learning question that I
have and then open it up to the floor so
invite everyone to please start typing
in your questions
um in the chat so I um I noted when you
mentioned you know generalizations right
so generalizations require
discarding details right and and hence
information right and I wonder how this
impacts what we can infer from
generalized data right do we lose
um or do we capture
um
so
um
do we manage to
um do we efficiently capture
what is really needed to robustly infer
or
well
first of all I think there's no doubt
that generalizations are articulated
with respect to what I would call
registration schemes which in fact
ignore lots of details in order to get
at higher level regularities and so on
um
when we
put those things in
um
in our system as it were
we may have other details so if you
think about
um I mean really some quite politically
problematic systems that have determined
you know recidivism rates as to who
should actually be allowed out of prison
and who should not or chances of success
in college you know and you know all
kinds of other things about this person
such as their
median income and the nature of the
neighborhood they're in and the racial
profile of the neighborhood
if we were doing inference in a
classical way which is say a conceptual
way we might actually just
three
base that decision let's say about
whether they should be admitted to Yale
um on their grades or something like
that
but if you train an AI system it's going
to use all of the other detail that it
has and that's probably not a
conceptually formulated filter
and the worry is that to some extent
well of course there are lots of worries
one is that the result will be a heinous
in a whole variety of ways that it'll
reinscribe you know
it'll reinscribe biases that are already
there
people struggle with fairness they put
in protected categories and so on and so
forth but you know that's a
that's a very tough thing to do I mean I
mean it's not tough to I mean people do
it but it but but ethically it's kind of
complex to in fact protect certain
categories because that's a form of
prejudice also
um
and I think that the challenge of these
systems I mean one way to understand the
challenge of the assistance if you read
these books like
um weapons of mass destruction and um
you know a book I prefer actually
um
by Brian Christian what's it called um
anyway
um
they document all kinds of problems and
sure enough these are problems but but
but what's going on with these problems
um
well I think partly you know in the fact
that you can't necessarily you might
think look I'm not going to put the
person's racial background or something
um
in this explicit variable and then these
systems can figure it out anyway
we don't quite know how to deal with
the richness in this statistical data
with all of the parameters right it
doesn't um tpt3 have something like 1.5
billion parameters yes you know what the
hell does that mean and and
but gpd3 is uncanny
um I went in as an exercise yeah yeah
that because I've published a lot that's
out in the world I said in style of
Priya right argue for X yeah it was
stunning I was stunned and it really
could have been my words
um and well so I I mean it is stunning I
think even the um
the the conversation that was published
with Lambda um
um this uh bot at Google which the
Creator thought was Consciousness and
conscious and got fired and so on and so
forth
it's really stunning I I mean if my
parents were still alive I would have
them read it it's like oh my God this
can in fact happen
now
one question is you know what's going on
with those systems should we trust them
and so on and so forth do they know what
the hell they're talking about and stuff
that's not this talk that's more what
the promise book that I wrote a couple
years ago was about and I think
the answer is no this is where I think
Gabriel's
notion of statistical parents actually
applies which is that you've written a
law enough I mean the space the space of
possibilities of the
construction of human sentences is
you know is stupefyingly large the
number that have been said is of measure
zero compared to that you've charted a
certain sub-region of this thing it can
be have certain kinds of patterns and
and these systems can recognize them and
stuff but I trust what you say
I'm not going to trust at least I damn
well better not trust A system that is
merely mimicking your speech patterns
you know I want to know what you care
about what you stand for what you would
go and stand in front of a bulldozer for
you know if a building we're building
we're burning down what would you in
fact do even if you never a
statistically run into the situation
where everyone's on Earth
so those ethical situations I think are
are outside the can of these systems but
imitating the style you know
it's damn impressive and I think it's
doing it because it's doing inference
sort of non-conceptual inference over
these details because computers can
handle a lot of data
but we need to understand that it's
non-conceptual we need to understand
what's the world like such that it's in
fact getting this data what was the
origin of data you know if we've got
something in there about how many young
people smoke and it turns out that the
data come from American Airlines and
you're only a young person if you're an
adult if you're over two because you
need your own seat
you know all these questions about the
categories the Norms of the categories
that's that's
that's the kind of question that I think
in a way I'm trying to sort of suggest
the the intellectual arsenal of
forms of understanding we need in order
to understand what it is that these
systems are doing not just to be
impressed by them because otherwise
we're going to be too bloody impressed
by them
I totally agree thank you very much so
we have a couple of questions the first
one is from Peter Morgan and he says
this perhaps a process or algorithm that
renders non-conceptual life slash living
into conceptual form but I think you say
one has to be careful about that process
I suppose we can have a non-conceptual
sense of how we render the algorithms
that perform the render but can we
render that algorithm itself is this a
reasonable question given that this
leads to a recursion
well
okay another glass of something to drink
I would need to understand what you mean
by an algorithm that renders can
actually forget the algorithm for the
moment I'd like to know what you mean by
rendering
non-conceptual life and living into
conceptual form because that would
suggest
assessing a a
life I guess a life process or something
of
probably ineffable richness and in fact
abstracting it in such a way that it's
fitting into a set of Concepts and I
would want to know whose Concepts those
are are they yours are they the systems
itself even if they're the systems
itself that doesn't prove that that
exhausts the life because I think most
of our life we in fact
most of our thinking is in fact not
conceptual in form I think
um
you know if you're driving down the
if we're driving in a car down the
highway and I am driving and I say
actually sorry I've just been struck
completely blind but I'll keep driving
you just tell me what to do
um
you ought to be scared out of your mind
um
because I can't you can't say look turn
a little bit to the right or turn 27
degrees to the left that's not going to
actually lead me to do the right thing
at what speed and so on and so forth
um I think most of our physical
navigation is in fact
um navigated in terms of sub-conceptor
representations
um
so I don't think you can I don't think
you can render non-conceptual living
systems into conceptual form unless
you're in an artificial life situation
or something like that and I think
that's one of the things that makes
those things inexorably and indelibly
artificial
um
conceptual representation is is
lossy right it it it it it
does and it has to and it's important
because it does
lose
enormous amounts of detail in order to
get that higher level regularities
the life can't in fact let go of these
oh details or it would die
so so yeah I just don't actually
understand I guess what um
rendering a non-conceptual life into
conceptual form would mean other than
describing in conceptual terms and I
think it's a theorem that if you
describe a knock is that full life in
conceptual terms you're going to be
missing a lot of detail
sorry I don't mean to be obstructionist
but uh but uh but I would need to know
what's going on better in order to know
if we can answer it
so we can move on to uh the next
question by Jun Lou so the implication
of this view for inference is the
question does it mean that inference uh
cannot be adequately licensed
conceptually that is if P given even p
and p greater than q and telling Q is
not automatic or autonomous but rather
requires non-conceptual orientation to
what p and Q are actually about likewise
the example of recognizing Priya and
Miami which AI practitioners today do
call inference seems to suggest that the
warrant of such inference is
non-conceptual with the non-conceptual
aspects
well I think um
I think that
yes so take the p and p tells Q um or
implies Q um if we go syntactic
um
there are reasonable conditions in this
reasonable conditions underlying even
conceptual inference of that sort which
I think even a logician would recognize
which in fact
limit the application of that so for
example
um
you know authorities paradoxes and so on
and so forth the p is standing next to
you then p is near Cube and Q is
standing next to R then Q is near R but
if you do that for 10 000 people then in
fact p is not near the person who's ten
thousand away and so on and so forth so
how do you know how far the these these
sort of partially transitive things go
um
um
you know the applicability of you know
somebody who's Young when you're younger
than them is also young and 21 year
older than them is also here
all these kinds of things um
it's kind of trivial for introductory
logic students to come up with examples
which violate the Norms of
of conceptual inference and I think what
the allergic teachers typically say is
look
you have to operate within a regimen of
reasonableness
the problem is that when we automate
this stuff in systems and have you know
databases being swallowed up by these
systems and so on and so forth we
actually don't know what the reasonable
conditions are and so on
um
you know this is an ancient example but
when I was in MIT there was this uh you
know as I said 150 years ago
there was this system of medical
diagnosis and it was asked how to cure a
a kidney infection it said take the
kidney out and boil it um now
that system lacks something
and so people tried to axialize Common
Sense and they've tried to accidentize
causality and they've tried to
axiomatize all these sorts of things
axiomization in the classical mold is
simply a conceptual rendering of what's
going on and I think the reason that
second wave AI has trounced
not necessarily forever I mean there's a
whole discussion here but the reason
that I think it's
kind of crouched
classical AI is that in fact
purely conceptual inference has proved
to be
inexorably brittle
because of the limitations of the
conceptual categories
and that
improved behavior of
these statistical algorithms I said I
think is because they are not entirely
conceptual
that doesn't mean they're the best thing
in the world I don't think for example
this idea of having a system explain
Itself by constructing literatures which
would constrain the categories to mean
what it is that they mean in these
particular things in soccer this is
Miles Beyond where we are now
but
yes I think there are limits to um
there are limits to uh
to conceptuality
and I think it's important for AI to
like you're coming about recognizing
Priya and Miami is considering friends
maybe somebody and I would call that
statistical inference
yeah
um
what can we trust statistical inference
for that's not that's a pretty core
screened
label of what's going on I think um and
I think the same issues about
statistical inference I mean the fact
that it's based on this idea of data
where the
data of these corpuscular things where
the assumption is that the instantiation
of the properties across lots of
different objects and lots of different
circumstances it's the same property and
so on and so forth I think they're
you know it's an advance over over go fi
but I think lots of these issues of
homogeneity
um foreign
not knowing the Norms that underlie the
use of the categories they're gonna
they're gonna defeat I mean uncannily
good as they look I think they're going
to defeat
um
they're going to defeat even this even
second wave inference I think you know
it will be looked at as narrow as first
wave AI inferences looked at now
thank you
um we now have a question from Sylvia
who was regarding the Precision of
athletic decisions involved in
navigating white water rapids I think
you were saying that because we cannot
conceptualize the pools then Brocks and
Eddies around a Bend notice that we
nevertheless steer and survive without
one causal inference non-conceptual
inference takes the limitations of the
programmers coding out of the equation I
like that but I'm not a mathematician
how would AI plant a garden oh I love
that question
um
well first of all um
yeah how would AI I mean I don't think
the word AI has a stable enough
reference to enable me to answer the
last question although my initial
gullible response was sitting down um
but
um
but the first thing about you know the
skill of of
of going through these this white water
with that one causal inference
I think this goes back to previous point
it isn't one causal inference in the
sense that inference was classically
thought about In classical logical terms
and AI terms it probably
is an inference in the sense that June
June the law was just mentioning that
that contemporary statistical AI would
actually take it to be causal inference
um
um
quite possibly continuous
you know
Dynamic interaction with an environment
in ways that honored causal
consequences and so on and so forth um
I kind of don't doubt that you could
build an AI even kind of at the moment
that could manage a canoe down some of
these Rivers um I mean I'm no expert I'm
not a programmer
um
so I think we have to know better what
causal difference means
um I mean
Bree was laughing at me I hope with
respect to my needing words well to find
um especially since I don't believe in
definitions but
but the issue of what the word mean you
know matters with respect to this stuff
because in fact by that one causal
inference we need to know what inference
is such that it doesn't involve it and
we need to know what inference might
mean in a statistical sense and so on
and so forth in order to know what form
of Attunement to the causality structure
of the world the systems are actually
capable of
non-goceptional interest takes on
limitations of the program is coding out
of the equation
you know that's very tricky um
I uh I just taught this course on ethics
of AI and this issue came up as to
whether the programmers are in fact
culpable at all for the systems that the
results they came up with
um
and some of the people who actually work
with current temporary AI systems say
look the program is doing nothing they
just programming cause you know gradient
descent among um
huge regions of you know spaces of
continuous variable and in fact
programming causal descent among them is
not doesn't take
genius um even if it pays you a lot of
money um
but there are issues about
what data you're Gathering and so on and
so forth which are pretty tricky I mean
if you have
you know a sex
um
you know a a
an entry for sex or something in a
database and stuff you know are you
going to have sex and gender or sex and
is there going to be separate and sex is
it going to be male or female or is it
going to be XX or XY or x y y or x x y
or X naught
um what about people who are X Y but
don't have Androgen receptors and so
they grow up phenotypically female and
they don't actually realize that they're
XY until they possibly get tests for
infertility later on and so on and so
forth and then it can be quite shocking
for them to discover that they've been
XY their whole life and so on right
these categories are not innocent and
you know and race of course is an
absolutely not innocent category when I
was a kid I asked my parents why I was
on a six or something quiet if a black
person a white person had a kid the kid
wasn't splotchy like a
Cozy Cow or something like this
and you know I got laughed at
but
I think the answer was because race is
not a biological category you know
and that's
the categories aren't innocent that's
what feminist epistemologists and and
feminist scientists and so on and so
forth have been arguing for so long
these categories are inflected
and partly what I'm trying to do is to I
mean I don't know if this comes across
I want to do justice to that recognition
from the science studies and feminist
methodologies and so on and so on even
though I'm
resolutely realist
because I actually think this stupefying
surpassing detail of the world is
actually the same
and if I and someone else registered in
different ways it's the same
detail that were in fact abstracting in
various ways that suit our particular
cultural assumptions and norms and so on
and so forth so and Brian is this is
this not much more Salient when we are
thinking of like standard you know
bottom of the barrel machine learning
tasks for example where we provide a
training set so the choice of training
set not only what data we collect but
what we choose as the Traders well right
and how the how the training set was
gathered that on and on and on yeah this
is this is um
um
yes absolutely
okay so we uh Peter has another quick
comment uh and a question you mentioned
that there is a lossiness in how we
think about life
thought is a compression is this
question well
yes I think it's a compression in a way
um I mean It's tricky because the word
compression comes from information
Theory and the idea is that there's
information there and
you know and the and the measures of
information in fact buy into these
conceptual assumptions and so on so away
so so so there's um
there's um
there's problems of circularity in the
foundation other question um
um
I do think that thought is lossy to some
extent but I think that
foreign ER I said we live in this middle
distance between the detail and the
abstractions and stuff and we navigate
them and we take ethical responsibility
moral responsibility for the
abstractions we have to I mean we should
anyway
and navigating them and so on and so
forth and understanding how they would
go into practice and and stuff and so if
I say to a surgeon look you've got to
um
oh and here's a real example from the
beginning of at Xerox Park when we first
made um windows and mice and the
question was how fast the mice the mouse
should track the you know the cursor
should track the mouse
and somebody wrote off a paper saying it
was I don't know whatever 3.5 inches
were
on on the screen compared to when it's
on the on the on on the
head or something like that and it turns
out that's not what matters what matters
is
you want to be able to cross the whole
screen with a single rotation of the
wrist
um
the
well I guess the point is it it is sort
of the same one that there's assumptions
in the categories
um
in terms of which we um
construct these non-conceptual
representations and so on and so forth
that we as programmers kind of need to
take
responsibility for
um
and if things are as Prius says and in
fact a lot of the problems are in how
the data is collected what the data
assumes and so on and so forth the um
you know when students I had in class
this week this semester didn't think the
systems were capable of taking at the
responsibility at all it didn't even
occur to them because they don't have
this model of AI that we had four years
ago in front of their own
so it's a mess it's a mess um I mean I
would say yes um thinking is is is is is
is is is is is
loses a lot
um but but good thinkers know how to
take responsibility for that which the
thoughts lose
thank you so Gary has the next question
what is the implication of scale for
example a concept of a person is fuzzy
but what about the concept of a photon
or a gravitational field a star is a
fuzzy concept but the fields created by
the star is precise
well okay so here's a problem
possibly with me I have never understood
what people say when they say concepts
are fuzzy
I may just lack the right Gene
um but
I've had arguments with this with I
remember John Holland and
John McDowell and and a bunch of other
people at Chicago at the time
um
is it that for example a person being
fuzzy does it mean that there are edge
cases which we don't
know how to judge
does it mean they're individual edge
cases are hard to judge but that we
don't actually
um
I mean one person at least we don't know
how to define it even though in a
particular case we would know how to how
to use it
um maybe we don't have to
don't know how to apply to detail like
bread you know let's say we have let's
say let's have the opposite of bread for
supper and somebody can say how can we
have the opposite of red right so what's
red is it hot cross buns is it Bagels is
it latkes is it you know non or chapatis
or I mean God knows what um
but is that fuzzy
like I'm not sure it's fuzzy it's just
not clearly applicable and it's it's
grab on reality is Maybe
you know
looser
um
stars of fuzzy concept I guess you mean
by that that um
um
maybe what kinds of fusion you need in a
in a system
you know there could be
levels of fusion which don't raise it to
actually being a star and this kind of
stuff maybe there are there are
conjoined star systems which are so
close that it's not actually clear if
it's one star two that would be another
in case it might be doing so the fields
created by the star is precise that's an
interesting point because
one of the things that I think is true
about computer science
um and to some extent by physics too is
that
we are used to dealing with systems at
an enormously wide variety of scales
you know I mean I think computer science
it regularly crosses
um like 15 orders of magnitude of scale
from from picosecond Junction transit
times to running times of ethereum um
mining um systems and so on and Earth
and some of the categories that apply at
some levels don't apply in others so for
example it might be that the
features or the properties I think they
might be features that in fact have
precise boundaries
at very low levels when you put them
together in this complexity you end up
at high levels without there being
completely precise you know
so take being a
being a
an implementation of PDF reading
that's truly fuzzy in some sense in the
PDF standard is nobody actually
implements it completely and you're
going to have things maybe for Microsoft
which in fact do a reasonable job on in
fact violate lots of cases and maybe
they accept cases which are not part of
the PDF but then practice goes with what
Microsoft does rather than a
specification and then it becomes true
that if you write it to the
specification it may not be accepted as
a PDF by Microsoft
you know or by Adobe acrobrocket or
whatever it is
what happens to precise precision as you
cross scale boundaries is
well I think that ought to be taught in
high school I I think these issues of
scale
yeah
how to think with scale
are are hugely important
and
um
I mean the implication of scale is we
should think hard about it and think
about what properties cross scale
boundaries and which ones don't
um
maybe that's my answer
leave the [ __ ] this aside right so I
think um at this time we we probably
have time for just one more question
before we wrap up and if Brian is
willing people can stay on a little bit
after uh officially to continue the Q a
uh so we have this question from Niels
um who says your examples seem to be
only on our perception and or
um
conception of the physical world would
your analysis also be applicable to the
social world and Concepts like democracy
or Justice and social roles like being a
judge a person either is or is not a
judge which to me seems a bit different
from the ridge example do you agree and
if you do what are the consequences for
the generality of your arguments oh big
question well
yeah fortunately I know Niels um
I would say they do apply
I think the the K I mean this goes back
to previous question early on about look
we have to have a social agreement or or
even determination of hack with respect
to category boundaries I think category
boundaries is um
if you'll forgive me an analogy I kind
of think of categories as as in the
classical model as being viewed at like
square waves in the following sense they
they are thought to have sharp
boundaries like the edges of the square
wave so something either is or is not a
judge as you say and then they're
thought to have flat tops in the sense
that the the the the being a judgedness
of a given judge is the same being a
judge and it says someone else
um and I'm not sure that's right and I
think that's one of the sort of
assumptions that is is
is so deep that I find it very difficult
to actually talk to students about what
it would be for it not to be the case
but whether a person is or is not a
judge
I would doubt that that's so clear I
mean
um suppose
I don't know suppose I'm a devout
Catholic and I want to actually
be married and I'm I've been hit by a
car in an accident and I'm only got a
few hours to live and stuff and I just
want a judge to officiate our marriage
so that I can be at peace and feel like
I won't go to hell or something like
this I'm sorry if I'm stepping all over
to 86 000 toes doing this but example
but it's
and somebody says well look I was a
judge I actually uh my my
um license expired last week and I say
look that's all right I don't care about
that right
um
my partner and I actually don't even
agree on whether we're married um
because we had a ceremony with her 95
year old father at the dining room table
the way that was classically done in
ancient times and we exchanged rings and
we had promises and so on and so forth
and it was wonderful because at the end
of it he stood up and raised the glass
and said
I'm so glad Brian you've done this
because I've always wondered about your
intentions and
um
you know only somebody 95 could say that
with a smile I think I mean it earnestly
and so it's worth it now to some extent
that strikes me as the authentic
marriage it just wasn't the one
foreign
recognized by the state accepting Canada
it is recognized by the state and so on
and so forth so
um
you know whether someone's a judge or
not I mean if you want to reduce things
to
the adequacy of
formal documents
then you get to what
nunberg was talking about at with the
rise of print and the sort of
corpuscularization of data and
you know that
the digital identity criteria of print
has in fact
first of all recorded social facts but
then actually become used as in fact a
determinants of the boundaries of these
categories and I'm uh
so I I actually with with enormous
respect
um and with an amount of respect that is
not itself formally measurable
I would differ with whether in fact
judges are or not judges
okay so I'm really tempted to have one
final question included uh Brian and
that's from Stephen hawkma oh okay great
talk uh near the end you made the point
that um these are not quite your words
um as he says representing Rich detail
is good for action but bad for long
distance inference but as your examples
show inference requires making the
normatively right abstractions that
retain the details that matter to the
context
this is non-trivial and I assume you
would say that the skill of making
context appropriate abstractions is a
form of a non-conceptual skill but if so
does it mean that we'll never be able to
explain the success of a generalized AI
if we somehow manage to achieve such a
thing
well great question
um thank you Steve um
I think that
yes managing the loss in a way that
doesn't do violence to what's
um what matters about the situation
um
is absolutely part of wisdom and a part
of being an adult basically
um
um I have an enormous respect
for that and I 100 agree that it's
non-trivial and I think one of the
things that scares the wits out of me is
that
we will not only model our AI systems on
essentially trivial models of judging
and inference but then we will raise our
children to think that in fact doing
judgment the way the systems do is
constitutes being an adult and we're
going to actually all
go down the drain because of our
conception of
Humanity has been torqued by our attempt
to build these systems and we're going
to lose exactly these non-trivial things
so yes 100 C and raise you one on the
non-triviality whether it's a form of
non-conceptual skill I actually think it
probably is um however you're not a
sentence I have to um
I had people worked in my group at Xerox
Park 40 years ago or whatever um were
going to get me vanity license plates
when they first came out and the vanity
license plate they're going to get me
was yes dot dot dot bet but
foreign
is actually sort of appropriate
does this mean we'll never be able to
explain the sense of of a general AI
first of all I don't think we're going
to get a general AI if it in fact buys
into the current idea of explanation
being entirely conceptual
if
being conceptual is taken to be this
particular model of conceptual that I'm
um
that I've talked about here um
the thing I was trying to say in my
epilogue comment about explainability is
and actually I mean throughout the talk
I didn't make a big deal of it but I
about anyone who was alert to it I will
have noticed
I don't think the use of words is
intrinsically conceptual in the sense
that I've characterized conceptuality I
think
poets and novelists and not only that
but I think great intellectuals and so
on and so forth use words in ways that
out script
the constrictions on conceptuality that
I've that I think have been kind of
lionized and brought into formality I
don't think we're going to be able to
explain
non-conceptual judgments made by even
even the sorts of systems like how it is
that a system decides that you've got
lung cancer or doesn't or was that
melanoma or not and so on
um I don't think
we're going to be able to explain those
things if we hang on to
the traditional notion of conceptual
explanation that doesn't mean we can't
explain them using words I think this
idea of a system can say well look it's
kind of like this remember this thing
happened to you while you remember the
feeling you had then you know it's this
person is kind of that state too but
they're also whatever blah blah blah I
mean think of what a really competent
doctor can do with respect to
explanation
it's often narrative informed
and I think there's something
really weighty and worth pondering about
the substance of narrative with respect
to explaining
in ways that outscript the model of
conceptuality I'm talking about here and
the question is
how will those be implied not only
in explaining the success of a general
AI but actually in getting us to a
general land
so see you and raise you one that's
that's my answer great
anyway
um I think at this point we have kept
you way too long um Ryan so I want to
thank you once again for a wonderful
talk we look forward to the discussion
tomorrow with uh Professor Rouse at the
same time uh 3 P.M as today and before
we close I want to give thanks to Thai
Camp uh without Dr Camp's help this
entire series could not have been
managed at all so thank you so much Tai
for everything that you do and in
particular for making this series such a
resounding success thank you and
yeah and to guy without who's AV help
and expertise we would not be able to
bring this wonderful set of talks to the
general public uh well for posterity
whatever posterity means uh with his
help and skills we've been able to put
all of these lectures on both our
website and the YouTube channel
dedicated YouTube channel so I invite
you all to go take a look and with this
I want to say thanks once again to Brian
and to everyone for attending and
helping make this uh wonderful series
such a success we are hoping to have a
conference in person next year in the
fall so watch out for uh details thanks
very much